important
because
Fac
would
to say
and
pretty
describe
time.
Eascepted
[Silence]
only
on a person
fake and
how do
people
Look at advertisement, modern-day
advertisement. What is the approach of
modern-day advertisements?
I want to sell products to people that
don't need them. That's the approach.
The approach is I if I'm a good
salesman,
then that means that I am able to
convince someone to buy something they
don't need or even want. If they don't
want it and I can still make them put
their hands in their pockets and give me
their money, I am a proficient salesman.
This is what what is this? This is the
epitome of fakeness. We look at
advertising and now we have entire
schools for advertising. How to
advertise, how to do and most of the
advancements that you see in our society
today came as a result of this drive.
How to make people buy garbage that they
don't need. And this is where we are.
All right. Everything from the
toothpaste to the colors of boxes that
your children reach for. Okay. To our
diet, it is all dictate to our laws and
the highest office
in our country and in our western
society. It is dictated by what? The
well-being and the welfare of the
public. No, by
the advertisement, by selling, by making
people churn and chug along the money
machine. And so this all roots back into
what?
And so a person when Allah commands us
here
these are synonyms when he says
[Silence]
Subhanahu wa tala
either
men
and so here observe the reverence of
Allah and be with the true and truthful.
Being amongst and with the true and
truthful is part of the reverence of
Allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala. They are not
[Arabic recitation]